>> This whole recombination thing
seems pretty complicated but really important.
>> It really is important in conjunction with the law of segregation and
independent assortment, it's what makes sex
so worth while genetically speaking. Now, it
allows us to mix and match different genetic alleles for the next generation.
But, can you think of a scenario
that undermines this kind of genetic variability?
>> Well, what if you started with a reduced genetic pool
in the beginning?
>> Well, that's true. And where might we
find a population of people with less genetic variability?
>> Inbreeding?
>> Yep, inbreeding. This genetic shuffling can be undermined if a pedigree
keeps sex within the family. Now genetically speaking, aside from all the
social issues surrounding it, I want you to tell me, in light
of recombination, what do you think the biggest problem is with inbreeding?
Don't worry about getting your answer right or wrong here. I just
want you to give me your best answer in regards to recombination.